I hooked up with the rapper I hooked up
with an actor I hooked up with a rapper
I hooked up with a rapper I hooked up
with an athlete I hooked up with a rapper
um this Canadian rapper was coming to a club in
my city I pulled up they took my weed at the door
so throughout the night I like see him and his
friends are like smoking up so I walk by they
make eye contact they tell me to come around
I go around We Vibe all night smoke all night
and the rest is history alrighty nice okay I
can't name draw it's Canadian rapper though
all right okay what's your story my story okay
so I met this rapper through a mutual friend
so then I went to his crib and then he gave me
his number and then we just kept talking back
and forth and then he'd be like come over come
over and I was like okay and then my homegirls
came over and then he was like I'm gonna go on
tour like you want to come with me so like we
all went with him we were there for like [__]
weeks and then we all went to Vegas together
and then like I don't know yeah we were just yeah
you know what happened really mine was Soulja Boy
okay so I just started working at a
talent agency and my co-worker invited
me to this actor's party barely knew
who he was but we bonded because he's
from North Carolina and I'm also
from North Carolina and you know
things happened and I'm not gonna name drop
you're mixing business with pleasure always always
my friend invited me to a kickback at the Ritz
and there was like a bunch of basketball players
there one of them liked me but I didn't know
who he was but I was like whatever I'm just
gonna like go with it and then we started
texting we hung out and then we hooked up
and his name was Melo ball I don't know
much about sports but I'm like okay
so I went to a nightclub in West Hollywood with
a couple of my girlfriends and they knew like one
of the promoters that was there and they were all
like oh we're having an after party at this house
and like the hills whatever you guys should
come it was like this big ass house that had
like a recording studio in the back and he was
supposed to be recording an album with Halsey or
maybe like a single or something like at the time
and then we ended up just kind of like vibing like
hanging out the whole night and yeah and then
things happened and can you say that's where
it was post Malone but this is like a long time
ago so he was like in his like coming up era so
different but okay okay I am a legal sex
worker and it was my boss's birthday party
and my celebrity was one of the performers at
the party so he's up there on stage he's doing
his thing he's singing and he pulls out a block
and he's like anybody got a lighter and I'm like
uh me hi so I pull out the lighter out of my
bag handed to him and then we smoke we party
we hang out we're vibing and we get back into the
limousine and I go back with him to his realm and
well as everyone has said things happen I just
think her story is too rehearsed there was too
many details bro it's like 20 23 like who the
[__] is rides in a limousine I need to know
if this is like your tactic if your tactic is
just like oversell the story because I feel
like too many details because I was sass of
you because there was too little details yeah
well I can say he was very very lovely in
bed that's for sure he had a really big
really big and I'll be real forward definitely
larger than average Magnum size I know because I
had to go and get one because he didn't have any
in his room I want to hear more about your story
yeah okay yeah did you know him when you like
met him like did you recognize him barely his
show had like just come out okay yeah I familiar
face but I I was it a reality show or like a
movie it's a TV show like a drama series right
well was he good to you in bed oh yes it will
bless you it wasn't easy do you remember it
or not what was his genre like actor single
actor he's an actor he's on a Netflix show okay
recent yes what's his ethnicity what what was he
wearing bathing suit because we were in the hot
tub did you guys like make out in the hot tub a
little bit did he use a condom never I'm just
kidding but I want to know why you have been
so quiet over here what do you have going on
you're just standing here how long did it last
um like five minutes not that long did you sign
any oh no you didn't not his name he wanted we
decided NDA like a year later but I just didn't
so oh so here who here did sign an NDA did anybody
anyone sign an ndi yeah it was like early enough
on in his career I feel like no one even like
cared oh oh hi are you enjoying this episode of
odd one out comment down below who you think the
mole is And subscribe for more episodes of odd
one out let's get back into the video [Music]
bye sorry I think they voted me off because my
story was just too good so how did you meet the
person again at the club is he like an A-list
celebrity he's like he's b-list okay it's like
good enough like I would know who it is yeah
okay would you do it again is he on the radio
um yeah he literally texts me
all the time what race is he
um he's Middle Eastern she looks away every
single time we ask her question she looks in
different directions I'm a really big even
if I'm lying like I'll be like this so you
every single time we ask a question you look in a
different direction she plays with her hair yeah
um what about you what about did he do anymore
Netflix shows after that this show is still
amazing I'm like should we watch it you
should watch it what is it called it's
too obvious I guess I don't want to say
how big was it I don't know I like to
call it the Goldilocks because it was
just right it was like boyfriend yeah
like August no no this was recent yeah but
he wasn't known but he has two seasons but he
wasn't known two seasons in one year I don't know
about that no he was he's known but it's the first
season does he have any other shows besides the
Netflix show I I don't think so ready to hook up
on a scale from one to ten I would rate my hookup
and eight because I would like a longer period of
sexual intercourse I don't know the experience
was like at nine a I don't know it kind of got
sheisty what got trusty about it nothing it
was just like there's too many people and we
already hooked up with your friends no he didn't
oh that's nice what about you um I would give it
like a seven because I was drunk and probably
wouldn't do it again and it was the Goldie
that doesn't mean there are other ones
I would rate mine a five because it was
too big and it was too fast and it was not good
it's like they don't know how to use it because
I think just like having a big is enough and it's
like actually so not true so bad and it's like
literally the worst it's not the size of the
wave it's the motion of the ocean it is 100 I feel
like this sounds Shady because it's not about him
at all but I would give it like a four but just
because it was like a lot of drinking and smoking
and stuff was involved so it was like we had some
issues like getting there if that makes sense and
then like I think we just gave up after like a
certain amount of time and I was just like yeah
like it's all good it wasn't his best performance
no no I'm sure he's great but I wouldn't know
though so I don't know we just haven't talked
to you guys that much this round so what team
does he play for yeah uh I don't know I don't
know about sports like I didn't even know who
he was when he was like trying to get my number
what team does he play for I don't know oh okay
purr we need some post Malone questions for her
yeah yeah even though we believe her but who knows
people when I'm lying I stare in here [Applause]
like I'ma look you down like it's all good did
you do it again did I already ask you that I
probably wouldn't one because I think he's like
wifed up with a baby now yeah I'm pretty sure he
has like a baby mama now and they move to Utah
foreign [Music]
she won't make eye contact with you when
she's playing with her hair and looking around
the guy she hooked up with had two seasons of
whatever Show on Netflix it just wasn't adding up
sorry
raise your hand on three okay one two three
I feel like we got them all out I still don't
believe you let's be like real about it so
like who are we like feeling collectively I
feel like you yeah that's what I'm hearing
too because I don't know Middle Eastern
Canadian rapper but like there's like
okay okay no shade no yeah no shade no love your
music thanks for smoking with me what about the
NBA Ritz Carlton were they playing a game that
day in L.A I don't know like I didn't even make
this whole team or was it just him no it was him
and his brothers and then like their friends like
two or three friends just his brothers play in
the NBA yeah both of them are they the ones at
the Facebook show yeah okay okay do you feel like
like I said earlier with like Alice I was like you
could be telling the same story like we could
have all hung out with these celebrities yeah
[Applause] I was like all right
how did you guys meet like I said I was at a
nightclub in West Hollywood so the promoter
he knew post Malone's manager somehow and they
like wanted to get a bunch of like hot girls
to like the Mansion when they were recording
yeah like what if it's one of the people we
kicked out already I mean um I'm like I don't
know whether to trust all of you or all of you
are lying to me because if you one of his [__]
lines I feel like it's there's still something
going on one because you keep on pushing to end
the round and then maybe she wants to be in here
us three old name jobs I know I've name
dropped in other situations on a podcast
and then I ruined that relationship
podcast what happens foreign [Music]
into the part a little bit too much like the way
she came dressed like the way she was acting she
kept on trying to end the game she's saying like
such a typical party story that she could have
just partied and went to the studio but like
not actually done anything with the rapper
and Avalon
we're showing Hayden you guys lost 30 seconds
so you two off the side together okay home girls
still sucks but she talks too much it's like she's
really confidently the person being eliminated
I'm sorry I'm sorry we have beef I thought
they were my friends I thought we were cool
there was an alliance there was a trifecta
and I got booted if you guys think that
there's still a liar among you three
you can continue playing one two three
wait to keep playing right yes yes the Box
turns red the mole has one and they are still
among you three but the box they're all telling
the truth at the cash prize [Music] [Applause]
I knew it
[Applause]
and on three the mole can
step forward one two three
I kind of believed you from the beginning oh my
gosh that was so much scarier than I thought it
was gonna be I thought I prepared enough but I
did not I do work for a talent agency a lot of
it like you guys were saying was a true story
I just added the hook up but if you were at the
party with this guy yeah I went with an actor
I am from North Carolina and the actor I chose
is from North Carolina so I thought that would all
check out I did [__] up with the seasons because
that's where I yeah who was the actor you chose
I'll tell you guys like off camera just because
it's like I mean everything like with the actor
is true I just like mix my story up a little bit
like what we like what you were saying yeah
yeah and you kicked me out we could have won
wait hold on what's in this
hello
[Laughter]